six-foot-four 290 pounds of talent and
terror on the defensive line his name
shavar Allen manual but those who know
and love on the most it is called Sam I
got shavar with me now and it's been a
busy month you've been all over but here
we are on national signing day where's
the letter of intent gonna go first of
all thank God my family friends and
other ones who disliked gave me support
throughout the whole process I mean just
my sophomore years been it's been it's
been it's been a wild crazy bride I mean
I love god I know to some trip seen a
lot and had a fun at the same time but
time is winding down in today's the day
to sign that letter but intent so
without without further ado I'm taking
my time is to wanna State University
baby Louis playback my mistake baby so I
love it I love it the family getting
involved now have our big moment also a
big change of heart what led to it I
mean go to state university I mean it
just just been a second home for me man
like I mean I have a love for all the
schools that that gave me offers and
supported me throughout the whole system
but identidad had to go to my heart was
that my family I mean we sat down and
talked about it and what stateless was
the best fish from not around there it
is the commitment of shavar manual going
to Florida State he is a member of the
hashtag tribe 16 yeah go nose baby haha